last month we paired with the incredibly
talented dakota johnson and her company
teatime to create a monthly must-watch
list that we're calling little yellow
book x t time top ten
now for i know
and dakota watches everything tea time
is her production company and she is a
phenomenal
like list maker so for november's list
we wanted to give you things to watch
that make you feel all warm and fuzzy on
the inside and here are just a few of
dakota's picks
hi everybody i'm dakota johnson
and today
on or this month on drew barrymore tea
time little yellow tea time
yellow
two times little yellow book
what are we calling it two times top ten
times drew barrymore
pics of monthly
favorite books i mean movies or tv shows
we have the great british bake off when
harry met sally
up
soul
won't you be my neighbor won't you be my
neighbor is
really great because if you ever watch
mr rogers when you were a kid
or if you ever watch it now it's pretty
soothing i watch it with my goddaughter
all the time and she learns a lot and so
do i
and
also when harry met sally is a perfect
film
it's just a perfect film it's the most
perfect romantic comedy otherwise known
as rom-com
and
[Music]
that's that
thank you dakota i love being your
partner in all things we can watch go to
our website for the full list it's good
[Music]
you